und jetzt das heute journal
ein kompaktes heute-journal guten abend
in alten lange nichts gehört von angela
merkel jetzt muss man sagen dass es
vielleicht nicht unbedingt zur aufgabe
von ex kanzlerinnen oder ex kanzlern
gehört den nachfolgern von der
seitenlinie neunmalkluge ratschläge zu
geben dennoch stellen sich ja aktuell
dermaßen viele fragen ob der
langjährigen russland politik von merkel
nach ihrem verhältnis zu wladimir putin
und ja auch zu ihrem politischen erbe
das interesse jedenfalls am ersten
größeren auftritt der kanzlerin hd heute
abend ist gewaltig mathis feldhoff
ein gespräch über irland soll es sein am
abend im berliner ensemble
es ist aber vor allem ein gespräch über
sie über ihre politische verantwortung
ihre politischen fehler und über
wladimir putin nahezu die gesamte
regierungszeit merkels ist putin partner
provokateur und pyromane gleichermaßen
auf der krim oder in georgien wenn wir
anfangen durch ihr hunderte zu gehen uns
sorgen welches stück vieh territorium
gehört wem dann haben wir nur noch krieg
das geht auf gar keinen fall auch ihre
haltung zur nord stream der gaspipeline
durch die ostsee erweist sich heute als
fehler insbesondere die osteuropäer
hatten das immer schon gesagt
gerade die politik deutschlands während
der vergangenen jahre hat dazu geführt
dass russland heute eine stärke hat die
auf dem monopol des verkaufs von
rohstoffen basiert
angela merkel will sich nicht
entschuldigen trotz der massiven kritik
auch daran dass sie mit dem minsker
abkommen mehr auf russland als auch die
ukraine gehört hat man hat im
wesentlichen muss und geguckt und wenn
russland irgendwo zerstörte hat man
versucht diese streitpunkte auszuräumen
auch zu ungunsten der ukraine
damals hat es uhr eingebracht und hat zb
der ukraine auch sehr viel zeit gegeben
sieben jahre nämlich sich zudem zu
entwickeln was heute ist und ich finde
den die den mut und den light die
leidenschaft mit denen die für irland
kämpfen und ja wirklich so beeindrucken
merkel wehrt sich gegen den vorwurf der
blauäugigkeit putin habe immer gewusst
was er wolle und es sei nicht gelungen
das zu verhindern
ja man muss sagen fall schafft geht
gegen das westliche demokratische modell
er will die europäische union zerstören
weil er sie als vorstufe zur nato sieht
wenn ein freund weg geht muss man die
türen schließen sonst wird es kalt sagte
einst bertolt brecht in dessen theater
angela merkel heute rede und antwort
steht sie hat die tür zu putin zwar
geschlossen aber nicht verschlossen
da gibt es noch fragen an einen
geografen der ex kanzlerin nachher mit
wulf schmiese im heute-journal update
und nicht nur angela merkel versucht
sich zu erklären heute auch ihr
nachfolger im amt olaf scholz ist in
litauen normalerweise ein besuch der
kaum große schlagzeilen machen würde
aber es sind keine normalen zeiten in
litauen sind bereits nato soldaten
stationiert die große mehrzahl von ihnen
aus deutschland rein geografisch so nah
wie er russland seit beginn des krieges
noch nie gekommen ist muss sich der
kanzler selbst verteidigen für seine
politik und macht gleichzeitig den
gastgebern ein verteidigungs angebot
natalie steger berichtet der kanzler auf
erklär mission er gilt im baltikum als
zu zögerlich zu zaudernd zu sehr
russland versteher scholz will das
abräumen wir werden im falle eines
angriffs jeden zentimeter des nato
territorium verteidigen
die politische spitze gleich alle drei
baltischen staaten hat viele fragen doch
zu den langsamen deutschen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine sparen
sie sich offene kritik bei der
pressekonferenz und stolz wie wieder
erklären es ist so dass deutschland
einer der wichtigsten militärischen
unterstützer der ukraine ist niemand
lieferten ähnlich großem umfang wie
deutschland es tut geradezu ermunterndes
lob dazu von den balten aber zu scholz
telefonat mit putin kommt dann doch der
wer solche gespräche führt muss
standhaft sein und einen klaren
standpunkt haben und genau das ist der
fall wenn wir miteinander sprechen es
kann keinen dialog oder kooperation
geben keine peas mit oder zugeständnisse
gegenüber einem staat mit
imperialistischen ambitionen
besuch bei den nato-truppen liter und
unter deutscher führung zur abschreckung
russland scholz hat eine zusage dabei
für die bald wir sind bereit unser
engagement zu verstärken und es
auf in richtung einer robusten
kampfbrigade zu entwickeln im baltikum
hat man sich zufrieden mit scholz
erklärungen aber die balken werden
weiter aufs tempo drücken bei den
deutschen versprechen
mit jeder und jedem allen die im
unglückszug von garmisch saßen will die
sonderkommission der kripo sprechen es
sind potenzielle zeugen bei der suche
nach einer antwort auf die frage warum
warum ist der regionalzug am freitag
entgleist warum haben fünf menschen ihr
leben verloren die staatsanwaltschaft
hat jetzt zumindest einen
anfangsverdacht und ermittlungen
eingeleitet gegen drei bahnmitarbeiter
patricia schäfer hat mehr dazu
der blick in die zerstörten waggons
lässt erahnen welche kräfte bei dem
unfall am freitag gewirkt haben
abgestellt sind sie unweit der
unglücksstelle bei garmisch dort ist es
ruhig geworden nur noch die lok und ein
letzter waggon stehen auf den schienen
um sie zu bergen müssen die gleise erst
wieder instand gesetzt werden weiterhin
wird nach der ursache gesucht und nach
möglichen verantwortlichen inzwischen
gibt es einen anfangsverdacht
untersagt leitung der staatsanwaltschaft
münchen 2 ermittelt die soko zug derzeit
gegen drei mitarbeiter der deutschen
bahn unter anderem wegen des verdachts
der fahrlässigen tötung nach
medienberichten handelt es sich dabei um
den lokführer den fahrdienstleiter sowie
eine person die für den zustand der
strecke verantwortlich ist die
staatsanwaltschaft hat tatsächlich ein
anhaltspunkt dafür dass sich die drei
mitarbeiter der bahn strafbar gemacht
haben könnten wichtig ist aber wir haben
es hier mit einem anfangsverdacht zu tun
das ist die niedrigste mögliche
verdachtsstufe die ermittler können
überhaupt erst anfangen die mögliche
schuld der drei bahnmitarbeiter
aufzuklären er hat sich der verdacht
gibt es anklagen wenn nicht wenn ihr mit
uns verfahren auch wieder eingestellt
auch ein technischer defekt könnte den
unfall mitverursacht haben laut bayerns
innenminister herrmann konzentrieren
sich die untersuchungen derzeit auf
defekte am gleis oder an den
fahrgestellen
möglicherweise war der streckenabschnitt
schon als reparaturbedürftig bekannt
nach einem bericht der zeitung die welt
warnte die bahn ab ende juni
sanierungsarbeiten genau an der stelle
wo der zug am freitag entgleiste dabei
starben vier frauen im alter zwischen 30
und 70 und wie erst heute bekannt wurde
ein 13 jähriger junge
und die übersicht über alles weitere
heute hast du jetzt hat die zahl der
gewaltbereiten links und
rechtsextremisten in deutschland ist
gestiegen das zeigt der neue
verfassungsschutzbericht
2021 dort innenministerin feser bleibt
der rechtsextremismus weiterhin die
größte bedrohung für die demokratie
erstmals gibt es in dem jahresbericht
eine neue kategorie in der akteure
zusammengefasst werden die sich nicht
dem links-rechts-schema zuordnen lassen
etwa verschwörungstheoretiker oder teile
der querdenker szene
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister erste mia
hat pläne für ein neues staatliches
tierwohl label vorgestellt soll zunächst
für schweinefleisch verpflichtend sein
und fünf haltungsformen kennzeichnen so
soll gezeigt werden wie viel platz die
tiere im stall haben und wie viel
auslauffläche mit dem label schaffe man
transparenz sagte özdemir
verbraucherschützer kritisieren das neue
konzept dagegen als zu lasch der
einzelhandel hatte bereits 2009 10 eine
vierstufige kennzeichnung eingeführt
allerdings freiwillig
wegen eines positiven corona
schnelltests bundesaußenministerium
berbalk ihre pakistan reise abbrechen
zusammen mit ihrer delegation soll sie
morgen isoliert zurück nach deutschland
fliegen erklärte das auswärtige amt der
board wäre eigentlich nach griechenland
und in die türkei weitergereist dort
wären gespräche mit regierungsvertretern
geplant zum beispiel zur nato aufnahme
von finnland und schweden
nur noch ein einheitliches ladekabel für
smartphones tablets und zahlreiche
andere elektrogeräte egal von welchem
hersteller darauf hat sich die eu heute
geeinigt ab mitte 2004 und 20 soll die
ladebuchse vom typ usb standard werden
so können laut eu jährlich knapp 1000
tonnen elektro schrott eingespart werden
kritiker befürchten dagegen durch die
neue regelung würden innovationen
gefährdet und jetzt die wetteraussichten
morgen ist es in der osthälfte
freundlich sonst kommt vom westen her
regen auf am abend mit gewittern es
werden 17 bis 26 grad erreicht
der donnerstag wird recht kühl mit
schauern zum wochenende setzt sich aber
immer mehr die sonne durch und es wird
deutlich wärmer und so viel von uns
allen hier in aller kürze gerne bis
morgen und viel spaß jetzt weiterhin
beim fußball
[Musik]